i really really am happy in my life
right now i feel like i've moved on
from the past love is still in the air
for
darcy silva i mean let alone i mean it's
a hot sexy bulgarian guy so
who wouldn't like that since 2017
90 day fiance fans have totally stand
watching the reality star
search to find the one first with jessie
meester
i can never have a good conversation
with really i can't really have a good
question
you're constantly judging me then with
tom brooks
you've actually helped me heal and
realize what i don't want but on her new
spin-off show
darcy and stacy it's all about starting
over
with her twin sister by her side having
two really bad breakups
has not been easy for me i'm ready for a
new chapter
i you know worked on self-love i worked
on things that i wanted for myself
vision boards
and releasing the past you know any
baggage that i felt like i had from the
past i let that go i
i cleaned my soul out you know and i
cleaned up
you know my life in different aspects
and i
am strong and empowered for my daughters
and
i have such a big vision in
my life for my heart and i'm excited
what the future holds
the 45 year old has moved on and is now
dating georgie rousseff who she first
met online
then in person at the super bowl in
miami a beautiful lady
oh my god i feel like i'm falling in
love again i've taken time to heal
myself inside and out
and i was ready for love again you know
i have an open heart
and he's an amazing guy he's someone
that
um has a different demeanor than the
last two thank god and
you know for me i feel like i get to you
know honor myself and say what i want in
a relationship he's very patient he's
calm
he's so understanding and we have a lot
of fun i mean i let alone i mean he's a
hot sexy bulgarian guy so
who wouldn't like that and when it comes
to her exes
she says there's no hard feelings i've
learned from the past i learned what i
don't want you know i'll cherish the
good memories
but you know all in all it was both like
a toxic situation
i you know never expected it to happen
that way
but you know i love big and i give big
and they just
you know were too hard to handle i just
didn't want to be you know involved
someone i felt like
was trying to lower my worth and i knew
i was going to rise about an
end i felt that for myself and i my gut
would always say you know listen to your
heart and if it doesn't feel right
just let it go and i did and i've
definitely healed from that but
you know my ideal is you know what i
choose now in my life
and i'm never gonna settle for less i've
stayed strong for myself and for my
daughters
and i don't look back you know i wish
them well i just for me know what i
deserve
and i'm gonna honor myself with that so
i've stayed strong and i'm loving life
right now i'm really happy
i've worked on myself i've done the
things and the steps to make myself feel
good
first and you know you want love and
you know really feel like you deserve it
you gotta love yourself first and i've
taken the steps to
honor myself with that not only will we
see more of darcy's love life
fans will also get to know more about
stacy's fiance
florian
he's my rock we're meant to be together
the two met
online five years ago he proposed six
months in and she has made
a lot of trips to his native albania
you will get to see a deeper dive into
my relationship
and go on this journey with me they've
been together in five years so they've
had to go through their ups and downs
and
she's definitely showed her strength
throughout this you know journey as well
and
he'll get to see little bits and pieces
of the good bed and ugly just like what
i have to go through so
you know it's real and wrong he's in a
picture with this woman with
hardly any clothes on penn state's
chance to
so what does darcy think of those
cheating rumors
i've had her back throughout it all i
just want her happy and she deserves the
best just like me so we are fighters but
we are givers and
we have a big hearthstone and she
deserves the best
i love just as big as darcy does i wear
my heart on my sleeve we're twins in the
end and you do have a lot of
similarities
you know she does show her vulnerability
as well just like i have you know we
think and feel alike so
there's a lot of similarities but in our
relationships there's some differences
too so and i know what i want and what i
don't want and
um you know i'm i'm good where i am
right now in life
i feel like with me and stays being
twins we're the closest
people to each other you know we we have
special bond
maybe not a lot of people will
understand but we feel each other's
energy
and what we go through yeah do we have
our twin tip for tap moments but that's
probably because we have a twin tuition
and we understand
what each other thinking and feeling but
we only want the best for each other and
we'll always have each other's back
but it's because we're you know we both
know that we're deserving of it so
sometimes it just you know we don't want
to hear it at the same time but um
you'll see those moments here and there
where you know we both want to have the
last word
or i just said i know but when you're
emotionally invested in a relationship
it's hard to
you know listen to what other people are
trying to say by what they're seeing
but in the end it's only made us
stronger and understand each other
and what we both deserve yes you'll
definitely see a
sassy stacy side and yes you know
you know but at the end of the day you
know we love each other yeah
we're sisters yeah she'll sometimes be
you know the quiet storm
right i know a lot of people have
speculation that i'm this desperate
varsity but i'm not you know i'm just
following my heart in the end
and while they clearly have a thing for
international suitors
they wouldn't rule out the possibility
of dating a local
we love american men i mean we've dated
american guys so it's not like we
never have or you know it's just but
that's just the connection
yeah the connection plus i think as kids
we've always traveled the world at a
young age we lived all over since
ages three london japan singapore all
over the us
and we tend to just like gravitate i
guess a little bit more towards men that
are
from a different culture and it's
intriguing for us and i think we it's
something in our blood you know it's
just not something that you know we've
looked for
it's just happened that way and you know
we've been blessed
we've lost our ex-husbands we're eastern
european even though we got divorced on
the same day
you know it's still a part of us and we
understand their cultures
and i feel like they understand us as
people as well so
but american men are amazing and i've
dated american men
and they're beautiful and amazing as
well so it's just the connection that
you feel i want to build a life i want a
future
sick of me tired of it